welcome to the session the beaker
extension for Jupiter pica-x
my name is tay jangly and before we know
the story of three cracks let me first
introduce myself and what I do so as you
can tell from my name I originally came
from China I'm a first name means iron
in Chinese so literally I'm Iron Man
so that probably explains why I started
engineer I graduate from Tsinghua
University in Beijing two years ago and
then I come to the United States and
received a Master degree in computer
science in Columbia University and then
I joined two sigma and become software
engineer here so into Sigma we find
values among the world's data and since
I joined to Sigma I've been working in a
team where our responsibility is to help
to build products to help modelers to
make data easy to discover consume
visualize and publish into Sigma and be
corrects if there's one of our
approaches of accomplished disco so
today I'd like to take this chance to
talk about beaker X its history
especially its relationship with its
predecessor the beaker notebook I'm not
sure how many of you know what beaker
notebook is so ever gave a short review
of beaker notebook first then never
talked about the path that to Sigma took
to come from beaker notebook to be here
X and for the latter part of this
session I will give a live demo for
pickaxe features so let's start it with
our vision for the Desai's what are we
trying to deliver so it starts with
discoverable data so we think that data
is the foundation for this data science
and data must be easy to discover here's
I say easy I mean not only type into
Google saying where can I find the oil
production for United States year by
year and you spend some time really
discovering the data in in tonight but
being able to integrate that data into
your research process into actual code
in a in a very straightforward way so
that's our definition of easy to
discover and after we have the data the
analysis and modeling portion of the
research process is enshrine in a
notebook and we
called a notebook beaker so basically
you're just writing code doing some more
experiments in the notebook and doing
analysis the analysis process is often
tightly integrated with scalable
distributed compute of multiple types
and finally what is critical is that
when you finish work you should be able
to publish your work to share your
findings and have ongoing collaborations
with all your peers so that's our vision
for the designs basically it's a
research prototyping and publishing
platform so we decided to be a beaker
and we have the initial thought of
beaker in 2013 so we built beaker based
on some observations you know any
scientific venture there's one key to
success is to write things down because
it's either publish or perish
so in the image you can see there's a
notebook and there are many valuable
images ideas formulas inside a notebook
we will never have a chance to know them
if they're not recorded so notebook I
mean the tools that we use to record
things become the foundation for science
and we agree that notebook is a really
good metaphor for user interface so what
we like to do is to upgrade this
notebook to its digital age and that was
inspired by Mathematica inspired by
ipython by the concept of repple so we
decided to build a notebook then what
else can we do to further enhance the
ability of this notebook and after
examine a lot of notebooks we come to a
conclusion is that language matters so
notebooks are actually written in many
different languages and there are many
different languages in the world and
each language is particularly good at
conveying a certain idea I think that's
really similar to computer language I
mean every programming language was
designed for a reason for specific need
and its own strengths for example like
as a data scientist today you may want
to solve your interview problems with
C++ for its efficiency to talk to your
data you may want to use Python or R
they're great library support to talk to
distributed clusters he would use some
spark and to read mathematical formulas
who said attack direct arguments for
others to read you use mock down so
actually knowing one single language
maybe not enough of doing those whole
stack of process and since we are
inspired by Python we see the Python was
gaining some momentum but it's only for
the Python community while coming from 2
Sigma where every support a wild mix of
different languages the noble we
pictured should foster collaboration
without locking our models into a single
programming language so in a notebook
that we have built we left language as a
variable for user to choose so here's a
list of all the languages that we
support in beacon logbook certainly will
see the Python on our at the very front
of this list and there are other popular
choices like Julia Scala groovy and so
on and don't forget there's JavaScript
that's especially useful for building
user interaction and visualizations so
basically in the pker notebook that's it
is composed of multiple coding blocks
and cotton blocks cells so each cell
could be written in different
programming language let's say for
example you use Python to redo data do
some pre-processing and then use R to do
analysis and there is JavaScript to do
the visualization so we think that's
natural because if you have a physical
notebook you're actually free to read
any language that you master and we
think this is essential because if
you're doing research or open problems
you may not know what direction you may
go and you cannot anticipate what tools
may be useful for doing this research
so this polyglot feature provide you
with the freedom to choose any language
that you think is the most appropriate
of solving a part of your problem and
this is especially good for
collaboration we know as a story of the
Tower of Babel where the unite
human beings are trying to build up
tower high enough to reach the heaven
and when God no this God is unhappy so
he confounded the people's language
speeches so people will no longer be
able to understand each other to
collaborate and then that project fails
however in beaker I say a modular
speaking of Python and a model speaking
R and a front-end engineer who speak
JavaScript they could collaborate with
each other as a granule level of cell by
cell because we have made a universal
object in set B cannot book to transfer
and store the underlying data to help
build this workflow so now the
researching process is more like a
synchrony rather than a solo besides of
those polygon features we also add some
more stuffs into the beaker notebook for
example we have an interactive table and
a rich charting library for time series
analysis that's based on our knees and
our understanding for visualization also
we build a public server so when user
finished another book he could upload
his notebook to the public server and
it's more like a Google Drive then then
he have a permanent link then he will be
able to share this link to his peers to
display his work and have ongoing
collaborations the peek has been very
successful because modelers inside 2
Sigma are using that to collaborate on
their work and it is very important for
us because it's our first open-source
project or coming from a place where
sometimes a post called a secretive
world of finance so that's a major step
and here we can see a lifeline for
beaker in 2014 we made the open source
beta in the following year before we
build more kernels and in 2016 we have
the external beaker lab that's exactly
the publication server I was just
talking about however in November 2016
we decided to do a pivot and we do a
pivot because we learn some lesson when
we are moving towards the open source
world so the first lesson we learned is
Beauty a community is really difficult
and the second lesson is once a large
community is formed around a very good
idea it's very hard for a single entity
to keep pace and yes we learned that
from Jupiter so true beauty is a famous
for its notebook but over this years is
it is not that notebook anymore
is it not Google it's not a notebook
alone anymore it has many other products
that support Jupiter such as the M be
present the M be viewer and be manager
and we convert and the new Jupiter lab
to be the hub and when Jupiter starts to
support multiple language kernels it has
gained a huge amount of users so people
are using it people are loving it people
are building a lot of notebooks with
Jupiter this ecosystem and it's used
more than just coding research but also
for education media publishing I mean
the trend is just in resistible
so as an open source contributor
ourselves it is not a good idea to
reinvent those views here the views I
mean the notebook interface and all the
other functions already provided by this
programs and certainly you cannot
reinvent a ecosystem by yourself so the
good things to do is to focusing on
adding values to the existing ecosystem
we should add values of our own
expertise and say our vision theory
science our expertise and data science
into this existing ecosystem to utilize
this network effect to benefit more
users so if we say beaker was a fork
from the original abstract concept of
the ipython then in the late of 2016 we
need to make a decision that if you want
to deliver our vision we need to do a
merge and join community and bring back
all the goodness that we have created in
beaker notebook so we made a pivot well
this could be a hard decision because we
are fear to move over three years of
hard work and point it to a new
direction and we don't want to
disappoint of users and we do know if
they would
the step with us or not so we submit
spend some time thinking doing survey
and they build a quick proof of concept
to test of ideas so our idea is not
forking Jupiter we're going to build an
extension for Jupiter so that we could
keep pace with the Jupiter development
well since the result of is so good that
we decided to keep on working to build
beaker X as the extension for Jupiter
and in the future for Jupiter lab I'm
very glad that we did it after nine
month of work in this year August before
to become the first version of pickaxe
was released and it is under active
development up to now so there are many
interesting facts in this development
process that I'd like to share so one
number is 94 this metaphor means that
94% of the code in beaker X was
unmodified and reused from the beaker
notebook okay so now you know that my
job is to add a small portion of the
remaining 6% of code to glue it to
Jupiter that may not be a good number to
mention for my personal performance
review well but that's why we have the
confidence to do the pivot and that's
why we can do that really fast up to now
we have we received more than 1400 stars
and we our active users have made more
than 200 Forks and make their great
modifications we'd like to see that so
what we bring on the table is a unique
addition to the Jupiter ecosystem so we
have provided with the following
features a time series visualization
more gvm kernels including groovy Scala
Clojure interactive tables and our
vision of collaborative collaborator
publication true polygon analysis and
data discovery so now let's just move on
to a demo to see what is reacts
I will first go with a demo that
mimicked the whole process of research
that is by discovering some data and do
analysis and fine
to the publication so let me show me a
little bit so you can see based on the
default interface of Jupiter we add some
new buttons here so you can say this
share button is used for publish this
data set is for open our data browser
and this is for running the
administrators yourselves which is it
exactly the first one you can see that
when I open this notebook the first cell
is getting automatically run because I
set it here so I guess they sell to bar
different cell you can see the mark is
checked so that helps you to do some
things like initialization imports or
setting API cheese so now let's just
start with finding some data so let's
open our data browser it's a better
photo okay so here we have a set panel
and it shows various data from different
data sources we have been doing this in
2 Sigma for years that you can if you
can name and describe a data set you
will be able to use that and now we are
building this ideas being this prototype
based on open source databases so let's
just take a look at this global
full-price database so when I click on
that that shows a bunch of metadata
showing this details of this data
refresh time frequency and we have we
have option button here to open it in in
ingham a public open source database to
have a quick look of all these data so I
say data must be easily integrated into
actual code so now we want to have this
table in our notebook so actually we
provide a code sample to help you do
this and this code example could be
easily drag and drop to anywhere in your
notebook and after that we could run
this and the table we just saw goes into
your notebook and becomes a panda tree
frame for you too many to manipulate and
do further investigation certainly there
are other databases and certainly we can
do
like a search here so this is provided
by quando for financial data and let's
say I want to know something like the
rupee dollar exchange so I will use this
code example actually I already have it
here so let me run this
let me see there's a table a normal
table but it's less interactive because
if you want to find some pattern in this
data we may want to do something like a
sorting or filtering and so we can use
speaker X interactive table so that's
just simply import everything from
beaker X then we call this data
structure again and that will be
rendered in the interactive way so in
this table we can see we can do sorting
on a specific column and we can change
the position of a column and certainly
we can change the size of a column and I
say you can change it to normal sorting
as I click there's a menu on this column
that provided with a bunch of actions
that you can do for example we can do a
filter here let's say I want to find the
high prices which are less than 1000 so
dollar we're referring to the current
value so you can see that actually
helped me do a filter and certainly I
can refer to other columns like let's
say high value less than last which is
not possible so let's plus 110 that's
done by a simple JavaScript eval to help
you do something like a filter and we
have some visualizations on this table
for example you can see there's a heat
maps the data bars and color by unique
and we can do that by keyboard shortcuts
I say I have a heat map here I can I can
do data power here certainly I can color
all of them by unique and now I can
reset all these interactions so if we
want to let's say I'm very interested in
this part of data so I can do a
rectangle selection without selecting
all the columns and all the rows and
then I can do a clip to a clipboard
let's say
have a Google sheet here I go to here at
press ctrl-v you can see the selected
data as long as the as well as the
column information are preserved when
you do the copy so table is good but
charlie is better now we want to do more
visualizations simple one with
matplotlib
it's not that interactive basically it's
just the image so with beaker X and
visualization we have better plot so you
can see we have crosshairs and we've
been moving to this big drop that were
interested we can see there are tooltips
may hover on that and want to see
clearer lets me let me just do two main
drag and maybe filtering out some lines
I can do a double click and recite this
interaction so let's say well this is
good so I'd like to include that in my
paper so if we have a chance we have
option of saving that into an SVG or PNG
even in a high DPI I say that's 4x
that's much clearer so that you can
include this image anywhere else
well good since we have fine we have
some findings now we want to share this
result so we can do this with a
publication here we will publish it this
as anonymous gist to get up and we will
use and beaver to open normal notebook
so this is getting upload and a new
window with MVP very open so now you
have a link you can share this with our
peers now let's go have a demo of the
polyglot that's the we will call them
Auto translation so here you will see we
have in our in in ourselves we made the
beaker acts as a runtime object this is
the universal object I was just talking
about and the data we are going to read
from CSV into a panda that into a
panda's data frame and by the way you
can see the pandas dataframe is rendered
with beaker in thrive table so that
actually shows the sleep and wait time
for a person
and then we'd like to put that data into
our Universal object so that JavaScript
script could read those data then I have
a cell to read some HTML basically just
define the styles that may be used for
visualization and now I have a
JavaScript cell which called the d3
library and here I pass in the sleep and
wake time in our universe object and
pass into a JavaScript variable and
after I execute this cell the d3
visualizations here actually showing the
sleep cycles quite healthy by the way
and now like us let's see another
example so that's a graph visualization
actually this small code of Python just
generated some nose and graph just like
a social network and HTML so JavaScript
cell and then finish that that gives me
a good interactive visualization for
social networks this is good because I
actually didn't write code from scratch
this to adjusts examples that I copied
from the d3 library at the website so
that a mystical collaboration you are
collaborating with someone in in the
world who is have his expertise in
JavaScript and what we have to do is the
resum code and prepare the data passing
the data to the library then can copy
and paste the code as you wish so let's
have a quick look at a groovy kernel
that's one of our GBM kernels for now
beaker accident book a pickaxe support
groovy closure Java code in Python
sequence Scala and this groove is just
an example so we will see all the API is
for plotting and table are working here
and certainly you can use code to
selectively show some of the columns and
you can use code to do visualization on
your table
as well as do more plotting set by said
histogram beautiful to use and you can
use that to build some custom actions
this may be interesting so you can see
that the cell in the very bottom is
tagged by rent tag and we have made an
action here that every point will click
if you click on every point that will
trigger the rent tag to run okay so you
can see if I click here shows I'm
clicking our orange points five five and
click here green points to four so
actually we have a lot of things like
even listeners to help you to do
interactive programs and I don't have
time for more demos but certainly you
can see a lot of new demos we created
here so we have more plotting and
chatting we have support easy form VG's
interaction and now we have made
connection with other libraries like a
table saw deep learning for J into the
back so actually they are working very
well with pickaxe for now
and this actually you can get this from
our website that is because calm so
everything will be here for your
download or documentation yep
that's for the demo and certainly we are
working on very on various topic to make
pickaxe more powerful so we are working
on migration to the tubular lab and we
are happy to announce the 0.9.0 it's a
release this morning and big X is now
working with Ruby the lab so it's great
to now and we are going to build deep
integrations with spark so you can see
that's in our vision the scalable
distributed compute which I didn't demo
so we want to build more deeper
integration with spark and we are going
to support data grace for streaming
table to increase the efficiency and
certainly we will continually working on
the true protocol analysis and the more
powerful data catalog
yeah besides those features this project
is also about
continuing engaged and meaningfully
engaged into the open source world and
to that end we have form a partnership
with nine focus and we have sent code up
streams and we have engaged with the
tributed community for example this year
February prank Ranger Jason growth and
Chris Cobra
they join us in TS open so that's a 2
sigma hack day open to all engineers
inside to Sigma where they can hacking
on all kinds of projects not only
Jupiter but also to be the lab ipython
widget and things like that we do this
because we know we have taken very
precious fortune from the open source
world and now we want not only
contribute back but also help in shaping
this echo system well the new tubular
lab with a bunch of astonishing features
such as the new user interface and the
real-time collaboration really give us a
promising future for this ecosystem and
personally I myself I'm very excited to
work on this project because we are
eagerly looking forward to and we are
working very hard to build a notebook
for the new era a prototyping
researching and publication platform for
the 21st century so that's the story I
want to share my pickaxe thank you yeah
before we go to the QA session I'd like
to say a special thank and introduce
someone who is my close work mate
who has teached me a lot who has been
leading the development of both the
kernel book and pickaxe who has created
great electric electric ship and being
called our software artist from to Sigma
Scott Draves
[Applause]
y'know Scott is very experienced and
technical and he has me leading the
development for beacon of books so I'd
like to invite him along with me for
this curious session for questions does
anybody have any questions ok the
question was what are the plans for
deeper integration with sparks actually
we want to build more interactive widget
with spark so actually you can adjust
setting the classroom numbers that you
can use spark and not only with code but
also with interactive a check like
starter job see the details of job
briefly it would be a spark
configuration panel and the ability to
see the progress the complete progress
information of all the jobs and stages
of your spark job the ability to cancel
a cell properly cuts cancelling just the
execution and the kernel is different
from canceling on the cluster and we had
a good integration support in beaker
notebook and we're going to improve and
reproduce that in beaker X thank you any
more questions
or you can feel free to come up to the
podium and ask the gentleman questions
if you want and thank you everybody for
coming thank you
[Applause]